but we had some Panda Express the night
before and I'm I'm just getting to know
her you know a couple dates and uh
everything's good you know in in the
night and I wake up in the morning for
work I'm like man I gotta I gotta
relieve this pressure in my bowels but
I'm late for work I don't know this girl
that way I don't want to do that to her
bathroom so I leave and I get about
halfway to my car and I'm like yeah this
was a mistake
um I don't know what to do now I'm
looking around for a shrub or whatever
but we're in a shrub
what do you mean Zelda or something are
you onward apartment complex so there's
there's not much cover to get around so
I'm thinking man I just gotta I gotta do
it right here by my door so I'm looking
around while I'm looking around about to
do it she comes walking out on the on
the like on the deck or whatever you
know waving my phone at me hey you left
your phone dummy so I'm like [ __ ] I
start walking over there and I get about
halfway through I'm like [ __ ] throw it
down throw it throw the phone down to me
I don't know
just come up here silly I'm like no
[ __ ] throw the phone down now there's
nothing worse than when someone calls
you silly when you have to [ __ ]
there's not it it's like
do you there is nothing silly about me
lady
I am going through
I am
reenacting that movie 300 right now in
my pants and you know you're [ __ ]
calling me oh hey silly you don't want
your food
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] one of your windows
open okay onward because I'm you know
yelling at her I'm not going up these
steps I'm just seeping seepage coming
out she comes down finally gives me a
hug gives me my phone oh bro is there
bro if you let somebody hug you
while you have [ __ ] yourself dude you
you sir are messed up man
you're a messed up dude bro and I don't
say that kind of stuff to people a lot
but that's insane man
letting somebody hug you while you've
[ __ ] on yourself
let that write that down
and then read it a couple times
Jesus I'll turn around
and I'm sure she saw those skid marks
yep
ah
I look
I think it's your issue Bob
that's what I think
I think you got a I don't know what you
got to do man I got no suggestion for
you bro
Dear God
oh
oh I can't now it just makes me scared
to hug anybody
and you're doing that to people dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one